yes but I told her that in farting
around the Pope was from oh hey sorry
didn't see you there coffee on a Tuesday
and vlog 44 so much of our personalities
and more importantly the conduct that
proceeds from our personalities is
determined by the stories that we tell
about ourselves to ourselves like any
narrative pieces are omitted to make the
story more coherent events are left out
to shield us repress to protect us for
good or bad but what's important to note
is that the story the story of us is
told fitfully not continuously once we
have a narrative that works we let it go
for a while events may occur
realizations may happen that contradict
our current narrative but we just put it
away in our subconscious only when
enough straws are piled on the camel's
back only when our current narrative
becomes glaringly unworkable do we pause
and let the issue rise into
self-consciousness along with all those
other festering elements we have for
time refused to see then in what seems
to us like a firework of Revelation the
story is retold the history is retold
and it's always a revisionist history
given the facts of new experiences and
understanding we revise the importance
of what's happened to us we see that
little things were actually massively
influential or rather we determine that
little things were actually massively
influential we are always the
storytellers it doesn't take long in my
experience once the need for a new
narrative becomes apparent I find that
the telling of it happens quickly pieces
fall into place like the subconscious
already knew where they were supposed to
go like the book was printed and I had
only to read it then the process resets
starts again the gears of a
consciousness work in a dreamlike
fashion we have the sense of constant
linear lives but instead were tossed
around from moment to moment in the
churning random imperfect sea of memory
and by the way humanity dreams too
this is what it looks like
200 years after our colony won the right
to determine its own destiny the task of
perfecting our union moves forward
until our bed and explored everyone
belief is the feeling is that they're
going to announce the discovery of a new
particle maybe
our mission is to make the world more
open and connected so let's do this to
have some new information when the
gunmen whisk was captured
gas masks and he told authorities there
are explosives in my record a majority
of those who died today were children
beautiful little kids between the ages
of five and ten years old they had their
entire lives ahead of them birthdays
graduations
weddings kids have gone
for me pushing it is important for me to
go ahead
that I think same-sex couples should be
while you may think you see better than
the others yes but I told her that
eating 18 pieces of bacon before running
her half marathon was ok sorry didn't
see you there yes but I told her that
robbing a bank with a pool noodle
probably Oh pay sorry didn't see you
there yes but I told her that no one
would want to buy a Christmas album of
all volkens song oh hey sorry I didn't
see you there yes but I told her that
Windex flavored ice cream Prabha oh hey
sorry didn't see you there coffee on a
Tuesday and vlog 40 40